I don't really care what people say
Tommy but the thing is any conservative
if they say one thing that is deemed an
appropriate income the thought police
income the politically correct team's
income the boycotts income the silencing
efforts so the double standard is so
obvious and transparent and you've lived
this as well as I have well the double
standard is all the left has to operate
on that's the only standard with which
they uphold but also talking about them
laughing about the the death of our
president this isn't just some Hollywood
liberal this isn't just Ellen DeGeneres
or Kathy Griffin laughing about this
this is an elected official who was
laughing about the death of our
president too far yeah I think so yeah
christen what if it's always the great
question what if it was Barack Obama as
president right would that with the
late-night comedians would everybody
they kind of gave him a pass especially
when you see the intensity in the
ferociousness against this president but
not only the president he's fair game
but his wife his young 10 11 year old
kid ya know the left has a nasty
seething hatred of President Trump
there's no doubt about it but the more
these tack attacks continue the more
that the 50% of Americans who turned out
in droves to vote for Trump are turned
off and the more mobilized they are with
regards to Harris's comment in
particular I think she was just joking
I actually don't have a problem with a
joke I can take a joke the problem is
the hypocrisy if someone on the right
said that Oh their career would be over
they would be shamed by every outlet in
America but there is a violence there's
a culture of violence that's kind of
growing on the Left I mean we saw Kathy
Griffin proudly holding up Trump's
decapitated heads
Madonna saying she wants to blow up the
White House Snoop Dogg's showing himself
assassinating Trump music video this has
become the new norm and and Tommy I go
to you and this goes back to Kimmel I
don't really care nobody really watches
Jimmy Kimmel I mean he's in last place
by a long shot but that's not the point
I don't think I don't remember anybody
taking those kind of shot
that he did a gratuitous shot at the
first lady go after the president go
after his policies make all the jokes
you want they're all there go right
ahead but it seems like that's a bully
and then when you look at his background
he's hosting the Oscars he's supposed to
be the face of me too and lecturing
America to really listen to the
important speeches and then he's got 18
year old grab girls grabbing his crotch
telling them to put their mouths on it
how did I mean he's like a pervert I'm
watching and I'm like we don't need this
and no conservative would do it nor
would they ever get away with it well
they are the late-night host they are
now the self-appointed morality leaders
but here's the catch they don't think it
applies to them it only applies to the
President and again going back to
comments made by jay-z who is another
thought leader for this generation my
generation we've got somebody who's
attacking President Trump someone who's
actually doing great things for the
black community we've got record low
unemployment rates in the black
community and we've got jay-z saying oh
white privilege Trump's a racist again
it's a distraction from all the great
things that President Trump is doing for
this country they can't take it that
he's winning so they have to call him
names that is textbook leftist